معنا من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
دكتور خليل ما الذي يقال في واشنطن عن هذا
السيناريو الذي بدا يتشكل في ضربات وضربات
مقابله من الطرفين ضربات امريكيه بريطانيه
من جهه ورد وتحدي من قبل الحوثيين لهذه
الضربات الموقف الامريكي بشكل عام عبد
القادر يقوم على محاوله احتواء
عدم الاستقرار في تلك المنطقه المهمه من
العالم هناك سعي امريكي لمحاوله وقف هجمات
الحوثيين واعتداءاتهم حسب المنظور
الامريكي على الملاحه البحريه لان هذا
يؤدي الى مشاكل كثيره جدا مشاكل متعلقه
اولا برفع اسعار الشحن رفع اسعار النفط
خلق بيئه من عدم الاستقرار لكن في نفس
الوقت ايضا التعاطي الامريكي لحد بعيد
تعاطي خاطئ الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
استراتيجيه خاطئه وتاتي بنتائج عكسيه يعني
حجم الهجمات التي نراها الان اكثر بكثير
مما كانت عليه قبل الهجوم الذي قامت به
بريطانيا وامريكا قبل حوالي اسبوع من الان
وبالتالي نحن اذاء منطق امريكي معكوس
هناك سعي امريكي لحفظ الامن والاستقرار في
تلك المنطقه من العالم لكنه في نفس الوقت
تقوم ب بما هو عكس ذلك هناك هجمات مستمره
ضربات مستمره كما تفضلت واشرت ضربات
وضربات مضاده هناك ضربات استباقيه امريكيه
وبريطانيه سواء كان ضربات لمنصات اطلاق
صواريخ سواء لمخازن مسيرات سواء لرادار
يمنيه وبالتالي هناك على ما يبدو تصعيد
واضح جدا من قبل امريكا في مقابل ذك تصعيد
من قبل الحوثيين وكما قلنا اتمر عبد
القادر نحن زاء منطق امريكي مغلوط الى حد
بعيد يقوم على علاج العرض وليس المرض
المشكله الرئيسيه موجوده هناك في قطاع غزه
موجوده في مقتله ومجزره مفتوحه دون سقف لا
سقف زمني لها ولا سقف انساني لها وبالتالي
هناك محاوله امريكيه لحمايه اسرائيل لان
معظم هذه العملات الت تتم في البحر الاحمر
تتم بالاساس ضد اسرائيل وك الامر اصبح
واضح لحد بعيد هناك استهداف للسفن الذهيبه
لاسرائيل اما وقد حدث اعتداء على اليمن
هناك اصبحت حسب الحوثيين اصبحت هناك مساله
مفتوحه اصبحت السفن الامريكيه والبريطانيه
هدفا مشروعا لهجمات الحوثيين في البحر
الاحمر طيب بالنسبه لهذه الاهداف
الامريكيه هل نحن امام تشكل لما يمكن
تسميته بقواعد اشتباك حتى الان الضربات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه لمواقع عسكريه
مواقع اطلاق صواريخ الى غير ذلك في
المقابل ايضا الحوثيين كانوا يستهدفون
بحسب روايتهم السفن التي متجهه لاسرائيل
او لها علاقه باسرائيل وضربوا ايضا سفن
محسوبه على الجانب الامريكي هل الى الان
نحن امام ما يشبه تشكل لقواعد اجتباك منين
الطرفين حتى
الان الى حد بعيد هناك سعي امريكي لوضع
قواعد جديده الاشتباك تقوم بالس على الردع
واحتواء الحوثيين هذا الامر كان موجود على
الاقل قبل حوالي اسبوع منذ اسبوع او
تحديدا منذ من الجمعه الماضي بعدما تم
الهجوم على اليمن على الهجوم على خمس
محافظات تحولنا من مجرد الاحتواء الى
الهجوم وبالتالي من الدفاع الى الهجوم هذا
يعتبر تحول كبير جدا
لانه يعني يعطي امريكا يعني منطق يقوم على
استهداف اي هدف داخل اليمن قد يمثل خطر
على الملاحه البحريه في البحر البحر
الاحمر مشكار الرئيسيه عبد القادر ان نحن
اذاء تحالف ثنائي بالاساس كل محاولات
امريكا للادعاء ان هذا تحالف دولي اذا غير
صحيحه هذا الذي يحدث في البحر الاحمر لا
يتم من خلال تفويض مجلس الامن ليس هناك
نوع من الاجماع الدولي او الائتلاف الدولي
الكبير بالعكس هناك بعض الدول الغربيه
التي حاولت ان تن بنفسها عن ذلك ايطاليا
مثلا راضت المشاركه بهجمات او بضربات على
الحوثيين فرنسا نفس الوضع الدوله
الاقليميه ترفض هذا المنطق وقنا اكثر من
مره اي صراع او خلاف حول الممرات البحريه
يجب ان يتم حله من خلال التفاوض من خلال
الحوار من خلال طوله المفاوضات وانا اعتقد
في النهايه هذه الضربات الامريكيه
البريطانيه لم تسفر عن شيء بل بالعكس تؤدي
لعكس ما رغبت او ما هدفت اليه اولا تؤدي
الى وقف المحه البحريه نسمع كل يوم عن
شركات وعن دول تقوم بوقف ناقلات النفط او
التجاره عبر البحر الاحمر هناك حاله شبه
شلل في في كثير من شركات الشحن العالميه
هناك تغيير المسارات من البحر الاحمر
وقناه السويس الى راس الرجال الصالح رفع
تكلفه الشحن
وبالتالي التي تقوم بها امريكا يؤدي العكس
ما ترغب ترغب في الحد الوحيد في رايي
وسيكون اجلا او عاجلا هو التفاوض مع
الحوثيين من طبعا يدعمهم طبعا بالاساس
ايران في هذه الحاله ما الذي يقوله
المراقبون ومراكز التفكير في واشنطن حيال
المقاربه الامريكيه حتى الان القول بعدم
بشكل صريح ورسمي بعدم الرغبه في توسيع
دائره الحرب في غزه وخروجها عن النطاق
جغرافيا والخوض في هذه الخطوات مع تحذيرات
دوليه ان الامور فعلا تتجه الى توسيع
دائره
الحرب هناك انقسام بشكل بشكل عام عبد
القادر هناك فريق يقول بانه من المهم جدا
توجيه ضربات للحوثيين كي يتم ردعهم وزجرهم
عما يقومون به في البحر الاحمر هناك يعني
في بعض الاوقات قرات مقالات تحريضيه بعضها
بالمناسبه حتى مدفوع من دول عربيه لن
اسميها الان لكن هناك دول عربيه من
مصلحتها ضرب الحوثييين في اللعمل وبالتالي
يحرضون كتاب في الصحف الامريكيه من اجل
تحريض داره بايدن على ضرب الحوثيين وقد
قرات مقال قبل اسبوع او عش من الان يقول
صراحه اما الان او لا يعني هناك تحريض
صريح و مباشر على ضرب الحوثيين هناك فريق
اخر يقول لا هذا الامر لا يحل من خلال
ضربات عسكريه يحل فقط من خلال التفاوض من
خلال الوصول الى حل وسط من خلال حل الاصل
المشكله هوو في قطاع غزه وهو في الدعم
العسكري الامريكي والدبلوماسي والسياسي
غير المحدود لاسرائيل وبالتالي هناك
انقسام في هذه المساله الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه كنت معنا من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك